Ciao Maryners e benvenuti nel primissimo video del 2018
innanzitutto ci tengo presentare la new entry cioè scimmietta quante carina la amo tantissimo come sapete salvo di chiama scimmietta quindi è insomma
sono, io
I veri mariners lo sanno che ho un debole per lo shopping in particolare quando ci sono I soldi insomma
combino qualche danno ecco questi sono I danni che ho combinato ultimamente quindi compriamo gli occhi alla nostra scimmietta così
Non rimane traumatizzata dai danni che ha combinato la sua padroncina e iniziamo subito
Il primo danno che vi voglio far vedere è un danno che non
Ho fatto io quindi partiamo subito super tranquilli perché I soldi non erano miei
E infatti ve. L'ho ringraziato mio padre e non è questa. La sua busta non. La trovo più quella originale
Il cappotto e dimas che è un brand che a me piace tantissimo, so se lo conoscete e
Questo è il cappotto che mi. Ha regalato a bit
Sempre per I saldi però madrid perché a votare se così instagram avrà visto che sono stato a madrid appunto per
Passare le feste con
Papà che viveva e niente da un sacco volevo rapporto di questo colore
All'inizio non ero super convinta non vi. Dirò che lo stupendo tutti I giorni infatti è uno di quegli acquisti che tanti di voi
Conosceranno calizzano non mi entusiasmano e che poi tavolo sfruttate più di quelli che magari negozio mi entusiasmavano un sacco
chiudiamo la parentesi regalo di papà perché adesso purtroppo
entriamo nei danni che ho fatto io
Quindi come I miei soldi
Da dove partire
allora questi video preti a madrid da other stories
e
Mi cacciano sacre volte mistico a milano erano tipo scusate al 50 quindi
Ho detto ma si è un colore che non metto tutti I giorni però mi piacevano
non
ci sarà occasione
vuoi non trovare un'occasione per mettere, I guanti abbinati al berretto a
buy
Poi sempre d'aver stories però qua milano, ho preso questo per avete già visto nelle mie storie perché
L'ho visto tanti di queste cose che vedete gli ogm se quindi non. C'è il cartellino perché chiaramente. Ho già utilizzate
E questo tour banchino qui che estra caldo mi piace un sacco è molto originale perché, non
È il solito berretto che hanno tutti e costava niente quindi. L'ho preso
Poi, ho preso un sacco di vestitini sono che il col fatto che alcuni li. Ho messi altri e ho lasciato il torino
Non ne ho trovati in questo momento che poggerà il video quindi vi
faccio vedere questi due intanto con gli altri farò vedere nei prossimi video sicuramente li indosserò oppure sinistra
Il primo è questo che è di forever twenty one
mi piace un sacco perché nella trentino come piacciono né
Perosino come piace a me e alle ma ritiene come direbbe mia mamma in stile vittoriano
è molto carina
E poi c'è questo qui che uguale a quello che avevate visto in un libri natale
Che vi è piaciuta un sacco era a bordo o questo qua è uguale nero di velluto e questo è di forever
Ma stiamo adesso all'intimo deve vedere o la bustina seria che sia di yamamay che di victoria secret
Di yamamay, ho preso due completini lo slip in entrambi I film sono lavare perché ne ho giocati quindi vi
faccio vedere solo reggiseno comunque sono abbinati è molto molto carino adoro questi due colori
Ha donate anche voi
è questo qua invece nero poi con una fantasia molto floreale mi sembrava molto primavera quindi visto sono già in punto primaverile
L'ho preso
Con I rispettivi clip?
allora passiamo subito questo per un attimo non è secondo
passiamo alle scarpe che non possono mancare
prima poi farò un video facendo vedere scambi
Allora tutte e due di steve madden
Tra l'altro un'era e saldo l'altra no
chiara nei giocatori negozi e punto subito e scaroni saldo ma siamo tutte cosi confermate venuta casa
quindi iniziamo da quelle in sat e da quelli in saldo è un semplicissimo e sandalo
oddio semplicissimo prof non è proprio subissimo però mi piace un sacco e
è tipo oro
Bronzo con tutti gli strass non rende tantissimo così ma vi assicuro che avere st de lio
La stessa indossarlo perché la pedicure cha va. Beh ne riparliamo poi
Quando sarà la stagione giusta. Ha comunque quest'anno 108 e avrò. Le ho pagate le forze
50 quindi direi top
il secondo paio di scarpe e
È molto molto molto poco sobrio se potessi riassumere questo paio di scarpe con una citazione
la situazione sarebbe
kira kira
può accompagnare solo chi conosce kira kira avrà già capito di cosa sto parlando
Ecco se la sobrietà avesse
Dei piedi ai piedi probabilmente avrebbe
Love
Creiamo, lo disse non me ne frega niente se alessandro meno perché tanto dovevano essere v e
vi dirò il tacco
basso per I miei standard però era troppo bella per lasciarla lì sulla mensola doveva essere
Mia e dovrà stare la mensola. Della mia strategia che quindi ero presa
passiamo a lui
Questo sacchetto ha una storia un po come la prada quindi ve. La voglio raccontare
L'avevo visto questi questa cosa che non ve la faccio ancora vedere prima dei saldi e mi facevo un sacco costano un botto
Non mi serviva e quindi ho letto ha detto sarebbe un capriccio lasciamo litri nel negozio
Però cosa è successo che anche stavolta come con la brava sono stato fortunato perché sono arrivata. Il terzo quarto giorno di saldi
è
In esposizione c'era lo stesso modello ma di un altro colore tipo rosino così I would e quindi ho detto
Chiaramente il nero che l'avranno fatto. Fuori il primo giorno di saldi figurati. Il normale chiedo. La commessa per scrupolo
va a vedere il magazzino e dino portano al nero
dicendomi si stata fortunata perché abbiamo esposto quell'altro colore senza pensarci nero abbiamo tenuto dietro e
quindi l'ultimo l'ultima taglia piccola, del nero la tua
Migliorativo wow
Salvo era tipo
sono contento per
il mio portafoglio meno
Ma bando alle ciance ve. Lo faccio
Lo faccio vedere
siete pronti
Ecco il cappotto più sobrio che mai avuto né l'armadio e l'uomo
Senza tacchi sembra un po un piccione però con. I tacchi che mi slancio a un po di più ma la sua degna figura
Ha chiaramente da coro nero e niente anche questo diciamo, non era necessario però lo spitzer mi sono voluta togliere
Perché fino adesso ne ho avuto uno che era un po
Rovinato gli anni eccetera eccetera è anche il colore aveva stufato e quindi lo cercavo così
Anche qui come per l'operato della stata fortunata perché entro appunto da prada e I primi giorni di saldi e c'erano vari modelli
ma colori un po
Colori che non mi piacevano oppure fucsia che come ho detto l'ho vinto per anni fucsia dopo un po ma anche bene cambiare
E come sapete per me o e oro o è nero poco a vedere all'esordio non è niente non c'era quindi me
Ne torno a casa con. La coda tra. Le gambe poi qualche giorno dopo sempre change il ripasso
C'era quel modello che c'era in tutti I colori stili in nero
Chiedo la commissione fa oggi, non. Ho messo neanche noi, lo sappiamo quelli che mettono
Cosa lo devo prendere subito cioè
ma questa gioia così in pista sta bene è in te lo compra chiaramente
Ci sembra affatto come potevano comprare un sembra brutto pareva brutto e quindi. L'ho comprato
Vi rendete conto che non. L'ho aperto fino ad oggi per fare il video per farvi
vivere il momento
Dell'apertura della scatola insieme a me cioè ragazzi quanto siete importante per me lavora una 3 milioni
Siete pronti
Per l'immagine degli stack e cioè normalissimo però io
Ho innamorata di questo portafoglio che considero più. Il gioiellino di questi falli e sono molto molto froud di questo acquisto
Come chiaramente mi piace un sacco e oro nero quindi proprio di così non, si poteva ma soprattutto a livello proprio di utilità
A tutti questi questo posto per le tessere che io veramente non. Sapevo più. Dove mettere di solito
Il portafogli, I normali non
Hanno
Tanto costo volete essere ti dovresti prendere comporta tessera parte dio sicuramente perderei può che essere che vanno da so qual caso alla
palestra alla postepay al profumeria ad hoc per ogni cosa anche per la farmacia e seconda testa quindi piena di tester e
Avevo proprio l'esigenza di avere il posto per mettere tutte le mie tessere e vederle cioè che di solito
Le mettevo nelle cassettine di dimostrare gli e guardare ancora lì ma
Infatti mi è capitato spesso che mi chiedessero scusa la testa e io per
Pigrizia e andare a cercare scovare dentro dicevano nel secondo
Non succederà più non succederà più
perché adesso il
portafoglio tattico oro nero di prato è bello è
fantastico
Siamo giunti alla fine. Del video spero che gli acquisti vi
Siano piaciuti fatemi sapere cosa ti è piaciuto di più a me chiaramente. La cosa mi piace il proprio
Di più di per youtube e lui non vedo. L'ora di riempirlo di tessere magari anche di soldi per adesso
Niente come al solito se ti è piaciuto il video mettevi un bel live che lascia di un commentino e se non l'avete ancora fatto
Iscrivetevi al canale e diventate dei veri mariners mando un bacione in seguitemi, su tutti gli altri social facebook in frenata e music a est